[MUSIC PLAYING]
WILLIAM DENNISS: Hello, and
welcome to our session "Deploy
Your Next Application to
Google Kubernetes Engine."
I'm William Dennis, a product
manager on Google Kubernetes
Engine.
And later I'll be joined by
Marshall and Cat from Fair.
In today's session
we're going to be
covering three broad topics.
First, we're going
to talk about why
you might want to use Kubernetes
in the first place and some
of the benefits you can
expect to realize if you do.
Then I'm going to do a demo on
deploying an app into Google
Kubernetes Engine.
And finally, we're going
to talk a little bit
about how to
introduce Kubernetes
into your enterprise.
All right.
So why should you use Kubernetes
as your application platform?
Well, first and
foremost, Kubernetes
is a container platform, so
you inherit all the benefits
of developing with containers.
These include things
like language and library
flexibility, so
no longer are you
limited to a particular language
in your production environment,
like a certain version of Java
or a certain vision of Ruby,
and no longer do
you have to put up
with some three-year-old
release of a library
that for some reason is
still shipping in your Linux
distribution.
With containers,
the developer is
in control of what
they want to run
and exactly how they
want to configure it.
You also get isolated
dependencies,
so you can run multiple
containers on a single machine
without them interfering
with each other.
And production and
development uniformity-- this
is one of my favorite features.
So your production environment
looks very, very close
to your development environment.
And in fact, if you have
a bug in production,
you can typically
download that container,
run it on your
developer machine,
attach to, say, the
staging endpoints,
and actually debug
the exact code
that was running in production.
Not only that, but you
also get uniformity
between the developers
on your team.
So gone are the
days where you have
to spend a whole day
configuring some development
machine with all the various
tools and things that you need.
You just install Docker
and you can immediately
be building these containers.
You can even have someone
on the team using a Windows
machine, someone
using a Linux machine,
someone using Mac, all
developing and deploying
Linux containers, or
whatever operating system
that you wanted to use.
And you get all this with
really minimal overhead
and complete resource isolation.
So, in the past, you might
have used virtual machines
to get some of these benefits.
By comparison, containers
are very lightweight,
both in the execution
and the low overhead
of the actual image size.
So back to Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is then
a container platform
that manages those
containers for you.
It does things like handling
how to schedule and launch
the containers on the machines.
It'll do things like reboot
any containers that crash.
It can even run-- continually
monitor them with health check,
so that it won't route traffic
to something that's hung,
or a replica of your application
that, say, is missing
its connection to the database.
It performs a lot of
operations like this,
all with the goal of keeping
your application up and running
without too much help from you.
So Kubernetes is a
workload level abstraction.
And what I mean by that is
you describe your workload
and it basically has the
job of running that for you.
So for example,
let's say you have
a server that you want to
run in a distributed way,
or you have a database
that has a disk attached
that needs to follow
it around, or maybe you
want to have a logging utility
that runs on every single node,
or maybe you have
a movie that you
want to render one
frame at a time using
the cheapest possible compute.
These are all
different workloads,
and these are all
things that you can just
represent in Kubernetes terms,
and it can handle it for you.
And I believe that Kubernetes
sits at the right level
of abstraction.
It's not super low
level in the sense
that you're not having to
deal with individual machines
anymore, but it's not too
high level in the sense
that it doesn't interfere
with what you're trying
to do with your application.
It kind of sits very
cleanly in the middle.
And for me this contrasts
to traditional PaaS,
which kind of like merges
into the application layer
by imposing a lot of
restrictions on you,
and also occasionally
even modifying
how the code actually runs.
With Kubernetes, these layers
between the infrastructure,
the application platform,
and the application
itself are very, very clean.
And I think that's important,
because when you're
choosing the application
platform you want to use
and when you're looking
at abstraction layers,
you want to prioritize making
hard tasks possible over making
simple tasks easier.
So Kubernetes, instead of
focusing on the easiest
type of application to
deploy, which is typically,
say, a stateless application,
and making that task easier,
it actually focuses
on making it possible
for you to deploy a really
wide range of far more
complex deployments, things
like machine learning batch task
or a database that has state.
And it can do all
this while enabling
a lot of really nice cost
efficiencies as well.
So I mentioned before
that containers
have really low overhead.
When you combine that
property of containers
with the power of Kubernetes
to manage those containers
for you, you can actually
really pack a whole bunch
of containers onto
machines, and you
can have a bunch
of machines running
at really high efficiency.
And you can even do
that in such a way
that it doesn't compromise the
availability and reliability
of your services.
And this is really
something I think
that's unique to Kubernetes
and one of the real big value
adds that Kubernetes brings
over just raw containers.
Kubernetes also comes with a
rich ecosystem and community.
So let's say you want to add
some logging or monitoring
service to your application,
with Kubernetes you typically
have the choice.
You can either get some open
source and run it yourself
or you can find a vendor
that can manage and run
that for you.
I think this is
really good because it
kind of lets you pick and choose
what you want to focus on.
Maybe in some areas you'd rather
have someone else manage it
for you.
But in others, maybe
you actually really
want to understand
how that's working
and you want to run it yourself.
With Kubernetes, you
always have both options,
I find, with pretty
much anything
that you want to try and do.
And, of course, Kubernetes
itself is open source
and, perhaps
equally importantly,
it's really widely available.
How wide?
Well, if you look at
the certified Kubernetes
program run by the CNCF,
The Cloud Native Compute
Foundation, you'll see
that there are currently
32 platforms that are
certified, 50 for distributions
and 14 installs.
So you really have a wide
range of choice of where you
want to run that Kubernetes.
And, of course, Google
Kubernetes Engine
is a founding member of the
certified Kubernetes program.
And certainly, not all
Kubernetes platforms
are created equal.
Kubernetes Engine was one of the
very earliest to go to market,
the earliest managed
Kubernetes product.
And we have a lot of really
robust automation capabilities,
things like cluster
autoscaling, which
can add compute resources
when you need them
and remove them in
kind of a quiet period,
so you can save some money.
We have things like
node auto repair, which
can monitor various
unhealthy conditions in nodes
and automatically replace them.
And we have node
auto upgrade, which
allows you to stay up to
date with the latest features
and security patches without
you needing to lift a finger.
Together, these three
features and more
really help automate a lot
of the operations for you.
And it basically means less
3:00 AM phone calls for you.
And perhaps importantly--
equally importantly,
I think, that the same team
that brings you GKE, actually
contribute over 40%
to Kubernetes itself.
So my team's contributions are
the kind of yellow orange line
at the bottom there.
And you can see that, not
only do we contribute 40%,
but we've actually
really sustained
and had a long term
commitment to Kubernetes.
This graph goes back
nearly five years.
And what this means
for you is that,
if you hit some bug in
Kubernetes or you're
having difficulty with something
that you just can't figure out,
well, I'm pretty
sure there's someone
on my team who's going
to be able to help you
with that problem, probably
the person that actually wrote
the feature that you're using.
And, of course, you get
all this with the benefits
of Google Cloud.
So all the benefits that
you're hearing about this week
and that you will hear about
this week, such as our world
class fiber network, you
inherit all these benefits
on Google Kubernetes
Engine from Google Cloud.
I really like this network.
With this you're basically
getting the benefits of YouTube
in a way, right?
Google built this thing
out to handle YouTube
and your little app can run on
the exact same fiber network.
And we're even deploying
undersea cables now.
So, again, all the
benefits of Google
Cloud in Kubernetes Engine.
And speaking of scale, GKE can
definitely handle your scale.
So I think this is really
important, actually,
that when you're designing
in your application,
that you really want to
think about scalability
from the start.
Unless you're creating some
internal only like lunch
ordering app, I'm sure
you want more users
and you want more scale.
But imagine if at that
very moment when everyone's
kind of beating
down the door trying
to get into your products,
at that very moment
of potential success, your
application falls over.
That's just terrible.
That's just the worst thing.
So I believe if
you start with GKE,
and as long as you follow some
good scalability principles,
we can be there for you and
ready to handle your scale
and set you up for success.
A great example
of such a success
is Niantic when they
launched Pokemon.
You might have heard of this
app last year, or two years ago.
And when they
launched, they actually
had the first day traffic, or
the first kind of week traffic,
was something in order of 50
times their original projection
and 10 times their worst
case projection of traffic.
We were still able
to handle that.
And, as you may know, the
launch was fairly successful.
So another thing
about Kubernetes
is it doesn't have
a very strongly
opinionated development
deployment workflow.
So you might think that's a
burden, in the sense that you
do have to actually set up
your own deployment workflow.
But, fortunately, using
something like Cloud Run,
you can actually get a
deployment workflow up
pretty quickly.
And the real power comes
in when you actually
need to set up some business
logic for your enterprise.
This might be something
like a vulnerability scanner
that you want to run
before every deploy
to ensure that no
vulnerabilities are getting out
into the wild.
Or perhaps it's just some
other admission control
that you just want to
check some behavior,
enforce something to make
sure your developers aren't
doing the wrong thing.
All these kind of
custom business logics
are possible for you to
set up in Kubernetes Engine
with your own custom pipeline.
And with that, I'd actually like
to invite up Marshall and Kat
from Fair--
have a lot to say
about Kubernetes.
MARSHALL BREKKA: Hey, everyone.
My name's Marshall.
CATHERINE CAI: And I'm Kat.
And we're from Fair.
MARSHALL BREKKA: Cool.
So if you haven't heard
of Fair before, you
don't know what it is, Fair
is a new car ownership model.
That sounds like
really markety, so what
does that actually mean?
If you download
the app, sign up,
you can search for
a car that fits
your needs and your budget.
Once you have that car, you
can give it back at anytime,
so there's no time commitment.
The entire thing is
a mobile experience.
You sign and pay for
the car on the app.
If you're interested, check
it out in the app store.
So I'm sure a lot of us has
gone through the experience
of buying a car.
And you've probably realized
that it's not really
a fun experience.
It's pretty outdated,
it's disjointed,
and there's not really
automation about it.
There's haggling involved.
You got to get
your own financing.
You have to get insurance.
And at the end, there's a ton
of physical paperwork to sign.
Every single part
of that process
can be its own business, and
usually is its own business.
Fair's decided that we're
going to try and abstract all
that into a single experience.
And that's what we've
done, but unfortunately
that brings a lot of legal,
financial and operational
complexities.
So kind of from
the start, we said,
maybe a service
or an architecture
is going to be a good
fit for us as we try
and build out a business
that literally didn't exist.
It's actually kind of a
funny story with that.
Two weeks before we
launched we decided,
we're going to add insurance
as a product on that.
And we were able to do
that because of the way
that we had structured
our services.
But with a lot of
services, comes complexity,
and you need to manage
that complexity somehow.
And that's kind of where
we chose Kubernetes.
But how did we actually
end up on Kubernetes?
We didn't start there.
The early Fair employees, we had
experiences at prior companies
with past products, and we knew
them, so we started with those.
And it was working,
but it really
only solved one part of the
deployment process, which
is really just--
or not process, but solution
for API servers, web servers,
background job kind of things.
It solved those.
But our data
scientist team, they
had really sub-par
infrastructure.
They were coming
from a prior company
where their training
was actually
done on a fixed set of VMs
and some in-office hardware.
So it wasn't flexible
and it wasn't scalable.
The way they actually did
their training is they
had to SSH into a box,
pull down their model code,
run the training code, and
then check back in on it later.
So they were actually
kind of having
to coordinate leasing all of
that hardware among themselves
in order to get
their training done.
So when coming to Fair,
they said, OK, we're
not going to bring all
that baggage with us,
we're going to
try something new.
And they were
experimenting with ways
of expressing their
training using kind
of like directed workflows.
But they needed something
to actually power
that system, they needed
some infrastructure there.
So that's kind of
where I came in.
I was like, OK, you
need this problem
solved, let me go look
around and find some things
in the solution space.
I was looking for something that
was relatively simple to use
and setup and could give
them on demand capacity.
So when they needed to
submit their training jobs,
we could scale up, and when they
didn't have anything to train,
we could scale down, so
we weren't paying cost
on that hardware.
Pretty quickly we
found Kubernetes.
And that was really back in
the Kubernetes 1.1, 1.2 days.
And took a few weeks.
We integrated it
with their systems.
And we got it working.
And it was a huge success.
It gave them all the
flexibility that they needed.
And after a few more
weeks, we realized,
wait, the workloads that we're
running here for their data
science training,
we could actually
be running all of our workloads
on Kubernetes, the API servers,
background jobs, et cetera.
So we cut everything over.
And honestly, our devs were
actually a little resistant,
because their previous
past products they were
using, honestly, were simpler.
But at the end of
the day, the ability
to actually have all of
our workloads running
on a single platform with
a single set of tooling,
that kind of operational
simplicity, really won out.
And we started pretty
small and simple
with just a couple of
services, but we've grown.
We're not a Google,
but we're running
40-some odd various
kind of workloads.
And Kubernetes has always been
able to run every single one
of those for us.
CATHERINE CAI: So
we've been running
Kubernetes for two years.
What are some of the
benefits we've actually seen?
Well, workflow customization.
So William actually mentioned in
his portion of the presentation
that Kubernetes has really
solid primitives for expressing
different workload types.
And we were actually
able to leverage
that to write a lot of tooling
to automate and abstract
our deployment workflow.
So what does that mean?
Well, we created these
standardized build and release
pipelines that simplify
how an application goes
from source to production.
So our developers actually can
spin up an entirely new service
and put it into production
and our platform team
does not have to be involved
with the process, which
is amazing for someone
like me, because I
don't want to spend all day
dealing with a developer
and helping them put their
app into production, right?
So how do we actually do this?
Well, it actually assumes
a lot of defaults,
but we actually give
developers the flexibility
to override some of the
default in our pipelines
to fit their specific needs.
So what a data
scientist might actually
need to deploy their app
is very different from what
a regular app
developer needs, right?
And my point really is that,
even though our pipeline needs
have changed over time--
in two years Fair
has grown a lot,
Kubernetes has always been
underneath, very flexible,
and been able to fit our needs.
So the next benefit
we actually got was it
forced us into very good
operational patterns.
So we don't have any apps that
are pets or special snowflakes.
And if you're not familiar with
the pets versus cattle analogy,
I'll spell it out
for you very quickly.
A pet is that one box that
you have in production
that you have to give a lot
of love, and if it goes down,
you're really screwed.
A cattle is more the box
that you can terminate it
and there's probably another one
that's already running or will
come back up very quickly, so
you don't have a huge problem
if it's down in prod.
So that's the way
that we actually
think of our applications.
We run our applications
to try and be
as stateless as possible.
And the reason for that
is because Kubernetes
can terminate your
workload at any time
and actually shift
it onto another node.
So, for example, your
node might actually
be suffering from
something critical,
like it might have very high
disk utilization or high CPU
utilization, so it might
actually terminate your app
and then move it
onto another node.
So as a result, the way that we
think about our applications,
it's stateless.
We try and run multiple
replicas of them.
And most of our
apps actually need
to be resilient to running
multiple versions at a time
because Kubernetes does
rolling deployments.
One other really awesome
benefit we got out of Kubernetes
was standardized
application visibility.
So with Kubernetes you
can see all of your app
logs, all of your app metrics.
They're all in one place.
And on top of that, you can
see what apps are actually
deploying to the cluster.
So with all of that,
we actually got
some really cool hidden benefits
out of Kubernetes as well.
We actually migrated our entire
workload into another cloud
onto GKE without any trouble.
So it comes to my next
point, and the long list
of things you're probably
considering when you're
thinking about
adopting Kubernetes
is whether or not to go
managed or unmanaged.
We're at a Google conference, so
really GKE or unmanaged, right?
So we actually started
on AWS in 2016.
And we actually didn't have
any managed options on AWS--
EKS, which is Amazon's
equivalent of GKE,
didn't come out until late 2017.
So we actually opted to
run unmanaged because that
was the only choice.
And we've been running
it for two years
and we've learned a
lot about Kubernetes.
So we've developed a lot of
really good in-house expertise
on Kubernetes.
But also, after two
years, we realize
it's actually a full-time
job to run your machines,
it's a lot of security patches,
upgrading your machines.
And I know that, for a
lot of people in ops,
you're kind of
worried about going--
you want to go unmanaged
because you don't want
to lose operational control.
I'm just going to
say, take it from us,
we've been doing
this for two years.
And when we migrated
our workloads to GKE,
we didn't necessarily feel like
we were trading off or giving
up a lot of control.
And more importantly, Kubernetes
is such a great abstraction
on top of cloud providers
that we transitioned and moved
all of our apps from
AWS to GKE and we
didn't have to make any
application changes.
But speaking of apps and
deployments, Williams
going to come back on
stage and he's actually
going to demo how to deploy
your app into Kubernetes.
[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAM DENNISS: All right.
So before I get
started with the demo,
I just wanted to quickly cover a
few key Kubernetes concepts, so
that some of the stuff in
the demo will make sense,
just if you're
new to Kubernetes.
So we'll start with containers.
Kubernetes actually
wraps containers up
into what's called a pod.
So a pod is, for Kubernetes,
the smallest schedulable unit,
meaning that these containers
get deployed together.
So maybe you'll have just
one container in a pod
or maybe you have multiple
in the case you have
like a sidecar container that
adds like logging or monitoring
or something like that.
So that's a pod.
Then we have a
concept called nodes.
Nodes are really
just a fancy way
of saying a machine, which
is either a VM or bare metal.
And the real workhorse
in Kubernetes
is a concept called
a deployment.
And Kubernetes works on this
kind of operative pattern
where you just you
specify how many
pods you want in the deployment.
So you say like, I want two
of pod A and one of pod B.
And then Kubernetes has
this operative pattern that
then seeks to drive the actual
observed state and the cost
to be the required state
that you specified.
So that looks like
something like this.
So say we have a
system, and we have
two of pod A, one of pod B.
And then, if one of those nodes
were to become
unhealthy and disappear,
the system would very quickly
notice, oh, wait a minute,
there's only like one of pod A
running now and none of pod B.
It's going to then
reschedule those
onto another node, at
which time it will then
observe that the desired
state has been met
and everything is right
in the world again.
So that all happens
automatically.
That's one of the very nice
things about Kubernetes.
And that operative
pattern applies
to various other
constructs as well.
Lastly, we have a service.
And so a service is just
a group of identical pods
that together kind of provide
a logical API service.
All right.
And with that, I'm
going to go to the demo.
OK.
So I was going to do like a
fairly boring hello world app,
but I decided on
Friday, actually,
to make something a
little more interesting.
So I wrote a little
server in Swift.
And this server is actually
using this other little project
at Google called Plus Codes
to convert a geographical
coordinate into a plus code.
Anyway, that's what
the app's going to do.
I picked Swift because I don't
think Swift is really used
a whole lot in production yet.
And I kind of wanted to
emphasize one of those points
earlier that with
containers you really get
a lot of flexibility.
I love Swift, but personally
I've really just not seen
too much being in production.
So if you do want to
use Swift in production,
I dare say that GKE is a
good place for you to do it.
All right, so what does
this little app do?
This little app, it's using
a library called Swifter.
I'm just going to start
like a basic HTTP server,
handle one endpoint.
I'm going to parse a
couple of parameters.
We're going to convert a
latitude and a longitude
coordinate into a plus code.
And then we're going
to return that as JSON.
Well, let's just
take a quick look
at what that code looks like.
I'm going to build that
container real quick.
And since it's actually
cached, it should hopefully
be fairly fast.
All right.
And let me run that locally.
And so I'm going to forward
port 8080 on my machine
to port 80 in the
container there.
Let me show you what
that looks like.
All right.
So this is the little endpoint.
And that's using
my example data.
So to prove to you that this
is real, let me pull up some--
an actual latitude and
longitude to throw in there.
Let's look at the
Moscone Center.
I'm just going to use
Wikipedia for this,
just a good source of
geographical coordinates.
So let me grab those--
whack it in here.
And then this is the plus
code for the Moscone Center.
So if you have Google Maps, you
can type this into Google Maps
and you can find where we are.
And when I-- actually, one
of the cool things about this
is you can actually drop
off the first four digits
if you're in the same region.
So anyway, that's my Swift
app running in a container,
running locally.
Let's get it up onto Kubernetes.
So on Kubernetes, on GKE you
can create a cluster just
with a few clicks.
I'll show you what
that looks like.
You just tap that
create cluster button
and then we have a
whole list of templates
that you can pick from,
so just pick the one that
matches your workload the best.
So say for this demo,
frankly speaking,
this little-- your first
cluster would probably
be quite sufficient.
I can leave all that as default.
Click Create.
Now, since that might take a
couple of minutes to come up,
I'm just going to use
this one that I created
earlier, which is Next Demo.
So let's take a look
at that cluster.
And I can click
the Deploy button.
And it's going to ask me
for a container image.
So let's get back
to the console.
And I'm going to tag that image.
And this is using a special tag
for Google Container Registry,
which is GCI.IO and
then my project name,
and then my application name.
So I'm going to push that up.
And, of course, looks
like my cache is gone,
so we're going to test how
good my wide connection is
to upload a gigabyte of data.
While we're waiting
for it to happen,
let me just show you a
couple of things here.
So Kubernetes-- we
show you the workloads
and the services
and any applications
you're running all in
the UI, which I think
is something that maybe isn't
available on other platforms
yet.
So for example, you can go
in, look at the services
that are running.
We'll see how that's going.
All right.
About halfway done.
OK, so while we're waiting
for that to upload,
let me let me cue
up some changes.
So after I've deployed that,
one thing I'm going to show you
is, also, how to do an update.
So the first update
I'm going to do
is I'm going to just
make a very small change
in this little service.
Let's add like a status field.
Like this one.
So let me queue that
up while we're waiting.
All right.
It looks like we are good.
OK.
So I'll go back to that
deployment that I was creating.
And I'm going to pick that
image that I just pushed
to Google Container Registry.
I can leave the
command as default,
because it's just going to pick
up the command from the Docker
file.
I'm going to give that a name.
Going to pick my
cluster, which is
going to be that demo cluster.
And just hit Deploy.
So this has now created
a Kubernetes deployment
all via the UI.
I can also take a look
from the command line
and see how that deployment is.
So I do this cube CTL get pods.
We're just basically doing
the same thing, but on
the command line,
just inspecting
the state of those pods.
And we can see that
already we have
three containers, three pods
running with that container.
So you can see just
how fast that is.
Now, the next thing
I'll need to do here
is expose this as a service.
So I'm going to go expose.
I'm going to leave that as port
80, because that's my service.
Pick a load balancer, so we can
access it from the internet.
And click Expose.
Now, that action will
take about 30 seconds
to complete because it's
actually provisioning a Google
anti-cast IP, one of
various points of presence
around the world.
So to save time
there, I've actually
prepared that one earlier.
So we'll go to the
Services tab here.
And we can see this service
that I created earlier,
and just take a look at that.
And so that is now
the same application,
but running in Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Let me pick another
coordinate to try out just
so you know I'm not faking it.
Let's look at, say,
the Golden Gate Bridge.
Using Wikipedia again.
Grab that latitudinal,
longitudinal coordinate.
OK.
And I said I would also
demonstrate an update,
so let's go back to the console.
We'll build the container again.
This time tag it as version two.
Fortunately, this one
should be quick to upload.
Sorry.
I need to actually build that.
OK.
Build it first.
And while we're
waiting for that,
let me get back into our
Deployment View here.
And I'll show you how to update.
So I can just go into
the deployment I created.
And I can use this update
action here, rolling update.
And I'll specify that same
image tag that I just created.
And I can also customize
just how quickly
I want this thing to
roll out, so by default,
when Kubernetes does a rolling
update, it will one by one
replace the pods
in the deployment
and it will do it in such a
way that there's no downtime.
If I really wanted that to go
out quickly, I can kind of just
say, you know what, I just want
everything to go out at once.
So we can try that here.
OK.
So now that container's
built, let me push it up,
and then I'll hit
the Update button.
One really nice thing
about Kubernetes
is, even if I
clicked that update
button before the
container was ready,
it will actually
handle that condition.
So it would actually
try and pull that image,
it would notice that
it wasn't present,
and it would try again
a few seconds later.
That's all part of
that operative pattern
I saying where Kubernetes
is driving the desired
state towards--
sorry, it's driving the observed
state towards your desired
state.
All right.
And if I go back in
here, I should now
see we have a new version
of the application running
just a few seconds ago.
.imagename.
OK.
That would be the reason.
And looking at the
UI view here, we
see that revision
three of my deployment
is currently in the
container creating state,
so very shortly that will
be available for use.
I can inspect the same
thing on the console.
And looks like it might
actually be running.
So let's get back
to our example.
Refresh that, and you
see we have that status.
So that's how to deploy and
then update your application
in Google Kubernetes Engine.
I'm going to show one
more thing real quick,
and that is how
to set up a cloud
build continuous
integration pipeline.
So let's go to Cloud
Build and let's
also open up the
source repository.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to push my application up
to the git repository
in the cloud.
And I'm then going to use a
continuous integration process
to build that container.
So first thing, I'll
create the git repo.
And I'll call that plus code.
I'll go back to the app.
I'm going to make
one more change, just
so we can observe that change.
Let's say the status
is now awesome.
And thank you for laughing.
All right.
Let's commit that.
Well, actually, before I push,
let me create a build trigger.
So now I'm going to Cloud
Build, into the triggers,
and I'm going to add a
trigger, so that anytime code
is pushed to that
repository I just created,
it's going to build the
image, the container image
in that repository.
So I can actually leave
this all as the default,
and it will actually build
my Docker image for me.
So now let me push that up.
And if we go to
the history here,
we'll see that a build
has just kicked off.
And, again, this is
going to take a minute.
But one nice thing is I already
know what the image name is,
so I can grab that.
And I can do the rolling
update right now,
even before it's ready.
So I'm just putting the image
name here from the Cloud Build.
In this case, I'm
going to say, I
want a max unavailable
of zero, so I
don't want Kubernetes to
take down any containers
until the new one is ready.
I will do a surge
of three though,
because I think there's enough
capacity to handle that.
All right.
So two things are
happening here.
Kubernetes is actually waiting
for that container to appear
and we're waiting for that
container to finish building.
Looks like it is underway.
All right.
Well, I think we have waited
enough for me to upload things.
So if you really want,
you can grab that IP
and check it out later, and
you should see my deployment
from Cloud Build.
With that, I'll go back
to the slides, please.
All right.
So one final word
about plus codes,
if you thought that was
interesting technology,
take a look at plus.codes.
This is a little project
that a bunch of Googlists
work on in their 20% time.
I think it's pretty cool.
There's also a
video to check out.
And I'll be putting the
code that I used in the demo
online later as well.
That will be the link
at the bottom there,
where I'll upload it.
It's not actually
available quite yet,
but I'll make sure that's
up by the end of the week.
So what are the next steps?
So now that we've got
our application deployed
into Kubernetes
by the UI, there's
certainly a lot
of things that you
might want to do before
you're ready to hit the go
to prod button on that.
The first one to consider
would be readiness and liveness
checks.
So these are probes that you can
configure in Kubernetes where
Kubernetes continuously
probes your container
to ensure that
it's actually still
running and ready to traffic.
Then, I think you want to
look at requests and limits.
This is specifying the resources
that your container will need.
Requests relate to
how much resources
get reserved when your
container is scheduled
and limits is the maximum
of those resources
that your container can use.
So when your limits are
greater than your requests,
it means that your
container can actually
use any unutilized
resources on that note.
Thirdly, I'd recommend looking
at configuration as code.
So you saw me just deploying
things and updating things
by the UI, which is
a really great way
to get started and
learn Kubernetes.
But eventually, you want
to get that configuration,
you want to download it
into your version control,
and treat it just
like source code.
So have any
configuration changes
go through code review and any
kind of security process you
have with your source code.
And through that you'll also
gain the ability to rollback.
So if you released a version
by changing the configuration
through git, you didn't
realize it was a mistake, well,
you can just do a git revert and
your configuration would revert
and Kubernetes will update.
Finally, I would recommend
looking at auto scaling.
So GKE in particular has
a really good auto scaling
technology.
I actually demoed one
last year at Next.
And I've put the
link up here for you
if you're interested to see it.
You can actually
set up a request
per second based pod
order scale, which
is really kind of cool stuff.
Basically lets you say, for
every 100 simultaneous requests
per second that
I'm getting, I want
to have like one pod backing
that, so if you get 1,000,
I want 10 pods.
That is something that you
can just basically state in
like three lines
of configuration,
and Google Kubernetes Engine
will make that happen for you.
All right.
So with that, I'd like to
invite Cat and Marshall back up
on stage, where
we're going to have
a bit of a conversation
about rolling out Kubernetes
to your enterprise.
Cat and Marshall.
Thanks.
So one thing we realized, as we
were preparing for this talk,
is your experience with
Kubernetes is kind of, I guess,
fairly similar to some other
customers I've spoken to,
particularly the way that you
actually deploy Kubernetes
into your organization.
So I thought it might
be interesting to just
have the audience hear from
you sort of how you introduced
Kubernetes to your org.
CATHERINE CAI: Well, yeah, so in
terms of introducing Kubernetes
into your organization and
how quickly you should do it,
I would say very slowly,
like glacially slowly,
especially if you have
a lot of workloads
that are already in production
that aren't on Kubernetes.
For us, we had the
benefit of being
able to start on Kubernetes.
But, I think, for
most companies,
Kubernetes is a huge thing
to bite into, I guess.
And so probably the
best thing to do
is to cut over non-critical,
maybe new apps,
into your Kubernetes
cluster and start
developing in-house
expertise before you
go whole hog into it.
MARSHALL BREKKA: Yeah.
Also, we had basically a
year to develop in private,
and more importantly,
fail a lot in private.
So that was sort of why we
were able to start with it.
But as Cat said,
start slowly with kind
of non-critical
things, because it's
easy to make mistakes like that
demo showed, where you roll out
your change and you've
got the image wrong
and you didn't set any safety
and suddenly your application
is entirely down.
WILLIAM DENNISS: And so
readiness checks for that one,
right?
MARSHALL BREKKA: Yeah.
Readiness checks.
WILLIAM DENNISS: And I'm kind
of curious to learn like,
what average level of
Kubernetes knowledge
does it involve to have?
So, for example, does the
typical application developer
need to know about
services and deployments
and yaml files and things
like that in a daily job?
MARSHALL BREKKA: Yeah.
I think for us, most
developers are kind of
at an observability
point of their knowledge.
They still are doing
some configuration
at sort of the deployment
and service level,
but it's pretty standardized
in terms of like that's
all they need to know.
There's a whole bunch
of other abstractions
that Kubernetes provides that
they don't really need to.
So I think we have some
power users, obviously,
who are doing--
I think our data
science team, honestly,
is on the further side
of that power user side.
And they're doing a lot
of interesting stuff.
And they really
are in the weeds.
But for most people,
it's just like,
let the pipeline
take care of it,
and then use-- keep GTL to
see, what does that actually
look like?
What's your state
of your deployments?
WILLIAM DENNISS: Yeah.
I remember when you said that,
I really kind of like that setup
where, if I'm a developer,
I can kind of not
use any of the Kubernetes
if I don't want to
and just focus on my container.
Or if I really
need to understand
how things are working
under the hood,
I have that level
of access as well.
And I think that kind
of, to me at least,
contrasts as to a PaaS, where
you sort of can't get access
to that lower layer, right?
MARSHALL BREKKA: Yeah.
WILLIAM DENNISS: And so
we talked about failure.
What tips do you have for
making workloads more resilient?
CATHERINE CAI: Just we actually
set anti-affinity policies,
so that basically means
telling Kubernetes,
hey, I actually want to
schedule pods of one deployment
onto different nodes.
This is actually one of those
moments where it's like, yes,
you should actually fail
privately, spend some time
really learning Kubernetes,
because this is something
that we weren't really
aware of, and we actually--
it became like a war
story in the sense
that, whoops, we
screwed this up.
We were actually
rolling over a cluster,
bringing in new machines,
and this happens very rarely,
but we had all of the pods of
one deployment on one machine
and when that machine was
drained and it was taken down,
we actually took down that
entire deployment and service.
WILLIAM DENNISS: So
basically, with Kubernetes,
if you don't
actually specify how
you want your pods
kind of spread out,
you could be very unlucky and
have them all land on one node,
so that's kind of--
MARSHALL BREKKA: I mean, yeah,
it'll just do a best guess
and try and fit
where it can, which
is great in terms of filling up
your VMs as best as possible.
But unless you give it
those hints, it's like, oh,
I'll put them all on one place.
WILLIAM DENNISS: And so since
you set up the anti-affinity,
how's it working?
MARSHALL BREKKA:
Anti-affinitively.
WILLIAM DENNISS: And
I'm kind of interested
in your journey,
particularly the sense
that you started unmanaged.
Did you want to elaborate
any more about that?
MARSHALL BREKKA: Yeah, sure.
I mean, obviously, as Cat
said, we started on ADBS,
and there weren't
options for us there.
But it wasn't
necessarily impossible
for us to run it ourselves, so
we said cool, let's go do it.
But it wasn't
really easy either.
And speaking very frankly,
it's basically just
the two of us who have that
institutional expertise,
and we're not seeing the
benefits that we really--
well, we're not seeing benefits
from having us just run it,
we're not--
like she said, we're
not giving up control
if we go with a
managed offering.
So that's really where keeping
up with the pace of Kubernetes
really, because there's
features coming in all the time,
and we want to be able to take
advantage of those features.
But then if it's like, we got
to do those Kubernetes version
upgrades and version roll-outs,
and that's just more burden
that we have to take on.
CATHERINE CAI: And just one
additional point to that,
I think--
I was trying to test out
istio, and it probably
took a week to get it
functioning just right.
We do have kind of a
bespoke multi-cluster setup,
so it took a little more time
to tweak everything and make
it work.
But on GKE it's a
one click deploy,
so that was really cool to
find out after the fact.
WILLIAM DENNISS: All right.
And the last question from me,
before we throw it open to you
all, tell me about preemptibles.
So preemptible is,
if you're not aware,
it's this machine type that
isn't guaranteed to even
be available and can kind of
be preempted and reclaimed
with like 30 seconds notice.
But you mentioned in our
prep that you're actually
using them, so I'm kind
of curious to learn more.
CATHERINE CAI: Yeah.
For actually all of our
non-production environments
and our data science clusters
we actually use preemptibles.
For data science, it's
actually a great advantage,
because we're actually
spending cents
on the dollar for those very,
very beefy machine workloads.
And then all of our staging
and sandbox environments
are using preemptibles.
And there's actually like a
really funny story associated
with it because
preemptibles are called
preemptibles for a reason--
and we-- this
happens very rarely,
but in the two years that we've
been running with preemptibles
in this setup, we
actually, on a weekend
once, got a ping from a
developer who was like, hey,
I don't see any pods
in staging, is it down?
And so we all, we're like,
oh, no, what's going on?
We like jump in.
You do QCCL get pods,
you see nothing.
And you're like, OK.
QCCL get nodes, you
also see nothing.
And you're like, OK,
cool, what's going on?
And then it turns
out that there were
none of the instances left to
bid on for those preemptibles.
And so we just kind
of changed VM types.
And then staging came
back up in five minutes,
but that is the risk that
you incur doing preemptibles.
So don't do that in production.
For staging it's fine.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Yeah.
I think any discussion
of preemptibles
has to come with
that disclaimer,
don't do in production.
But it's interesting
because you have
like non-production workloads
that are still kind of very
important to the business, like
machine learning even, that
just don't necessarily
need [INAUDIBLE]
completed by a certain time.
MARSHALL BREKKA: Yeah.
And I mean, I think
especially with those ones,
it's important to
remember, as she said,
once we had changed
the instance type
and our nodes were
able to come back in,
Kubernetes was just like,
oh, the state of the world
is not in the desired state,
so I need to put it back
into the desired state.
So like with machine learning
and the training models
they were doing there, if
the nodes just went away,
and then eventually they
came back, it'd be like,
oh, there's still
workloads I need to finish.
And then it would go
and make them happen.
So that was kind of like
a pseudo disaster recovery
kind of scenario.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Yeah.
I definitely think using
preemptibles without Kubernetes
would be really, really hot.
You basically build
Kubernetes, I think.
So anyway, cool.
Well, with that, that's the
end of our prepared content.
But it looks like we
have about three minutes,
if you have any questions.
And there's also been a Dory.
So, I believe, if there's
any Dory questions,
we'll have those now as well.
But thank you, everyone,
for joining us today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]